we knew it was coming but still it takes
the breath away the impact of Britain's
virus locked down now writ large in the
official statistics 18 years of economic
growth evaporating in the space of two
months I'm not I'm free I'm afraid
surprised by the figures that we've seen
and that UK is heavily dependent on
services we're a dynamic creative
economy we depend so much on on human
contact we having very hit badly hit by
by this but we're also amazingly
resilient and creative we will bounce
back you only get a sense of the scale
of this downturn when you compare it
with the trajectories of every other
recession in recent decades none of them
the 70s 90s or 2008 crash so much more
than a 5 percent fall but the data
suggests the scale of this recession
already Dwarfs every other recession on
recent record the question now is how
quickly we bounce back and on that front
the Bank of England governor says
there's some grounds for hope we see
signs of the economy now beginning to
come back into life in the
high-frequency data we do see that it's
early days and obviously I don't want to
emphasize too much it's you know it's a
gradual coming back into life but we do
see those signs so you stand ready to
take out so we stand ready to take
action we do but what does a recession
actually mean it's simply the aggregate
number for what so many people are
experiencing up and down the country a
collapse in demand for their products
and services consider what happened to
Sanjay's family's business which sells
spices it was quite a quick hit
especially when when the supermarket
zone is kind of panic buying in the
supermarket's
nobody was going online and buying our
kind of products at that time so I would
say end of March through to early April
we were affected both through
wholesalers and shops shutting as well
as online the high street has borne much
of the brunt one of the worst affected
sectors alongside hotels and restaurants
this comic book retailer worries for the
future I think the biggest issue cross
is is just getting food I guess a court
will of not having any trade because
there's a there's a ton of money there
that we've not had obviously landlords
need to be paid here in the City of
London like everywhere else mostly
deserted there were mixed reactions to
the
point four percent fall in output the
funny thing is this economic contraction
is both shocking and yet altogether
predictable in fact talking to analysts
at the Bank of England they say it's
more or less in line with where they
expected the economy to be based on
their latest scenario even so this is a
historic moment we have never before
seen the economy shrink this much so
fast and the hope is we never do again
as Britain fights the virus it finds
itself in a new era radical numbers on
the economy radical uncertainty about
the future Eddie Conway Sky News